anti-gun activists in the u.s. have been
pushing for gun law reform Australia
having made substantial changes to its
gun laws is often held as an example the
country has a very low rate of gun
related homicide when compared to the US
where people are at least 20 times more
likely to be murdered by firearms
stricter gun controls can't stop every
mass shooting but they have made
Australia significantly safer place
here's how Australia used to have a
serious problem with gun violence
researchers define mass shootings as
five or more deaths not including the
perpetrator from 1979 to 1996 there were
13 mass shootings resulting in over 100
deaths and more than 50 injuries however
due to the gun lobby and politicians
sympathetic to their firearm owning
voters little was done to stop gun
deaths
in April 1996 that all changed on the
island of Tasmania the worst massacre in
Australian history is finally over at
least 34 people were killed and 4 others
critically wounded armed with two rifles
an ar-15 and a 308
FN Martin Bryant made his way through
Port Arthur historic site killing 35
people and injuring a further 23 both
guns were semi-automatic rapid-fire
weapons and both were legal in the state
of Tasmania of the time the Port Arthur
massacre was the worst single person
mass shooting in global history it
utterly shocked Australians and
reignited public outrage just 12 days
later the then Prime Minister John
Howard pushed through a sweeping set of
gun regulations despite a lack of
support from his rural constituency
[Music]
within a month the government passed the
National Firearms agreement transforming
gun legislation in the country before
the Port Arthur massacre gun laws varied
from state to state what the agreement
did was standardized their laws
nationally a certain semi-automatics and
self-loading rifles and shotguns were
banned new licensing requirements were
adopted and a National Firearms Registry
was established the law says Australians
need a genuine reason for having a
firearm such a sports shooting or for
agricultural use it doesn't include
self-defense people must go through
background checks and wait 28 days
before they can buy a gun
the government also spent 375 million
u.s. dollars to buy back six hundred and
forty thousand civilian owned guns and
then destroyed them after the gun law
reform the total number of homicides
involving a firearm decreased by half
the total number of gun related deaths
fell rapidly as well dropping more than
half in 2016 compared with 1996
Australia didn't see a single mass
shooting from 1996 to 2018 more than 22
years however anti-gun activist warned
that following years of lobbying by
pro-gun groups Australia's strict gun
laws have been eroded and gun numbers
are almost back to the same level as at
the time of the Port Arthur massacre in
May 2018 a family of seven including
four children were shot dead in an
apparent murder-suicide
in the state of Western Australia this
brought back painful memories and
uncertainty about the issue many thought
had been resolved Australia is not
totally immune to mass shootings but its
response to the Port Arthur massacre
demonstrated how strong political
leadership and strict gun control
policies can help curb violence and save
lives
[Music]
you
you